on a cold afternoon in Western Canada a
community comes together to grieve the
loss of a close friend and celebrate her
life dr. Scheck afar Shabana had worked
as an obstetrician in Edmonton often
helping recent immigrants she and her
two teenage daughters both of whom were
studying to become medical professionals
died on board Ukraine International
Airlines flight 752 as they were
returning to Canada from Iran for my
friend dr. superfish she was absolutely
a kind person she was always there for
the community she was always there to
step in when help needed so losing her
it's a big loss for the Persian
community 57 Canadians died when their
plane was shot down by an Iranian
missile shortly after taking off from
Tehran 13 members of Edmonton's Iranian
community died in the crash the largest
single loss of life the city has seen
for decades
Edmonton small tight-knit Iranian
Canadian community has been devastated
in the Persian restaurants and cafes and
on online chat groups it seems everybody
knows everybody else when you're just
hitting the news it's not something that
you say but did this really happen for a
restaurateur like ours that we have seen
these people they just take deep
connection this is like kind of a small
family of this restaurant the part of
the story is with the people that we see
all the time if it's difficult it's very
tough the tragedy struck Edmonton's
academic community particularly hard at
least 10 of the victims were students
staff or alumni here at the University
of Alberta their friends say they were
some of the brightest and the best their
lives and their contributions to society
cut short Peyman parson is mourning the
loss of his friend professor Pedram
Mousavi his wife and their two young
daughters describing them as role models
in the community you can see the outpour
of messages from people all across this
country it's it shows the grave impact
that's such an unfortunate incident has
on not just the Iranian Canadian
community but Canada as a whole
fundraisers to help pay for memorials
and create scholarship
are another way people here are honoring
their friends aiming to make sure that
those who were lost will not be
forgotten
David Mercer al Jazeera Edmonton Canada